NARRATOR: Vedic scholars
suggest that not only were
the ancient Hindus able
to perform brain surgery,
but other advanced
procedures as well.
And much of this
medical knowledge
was set to record in a Sanskrit
text dating back to 800 BC,
known as the Sushruta Samhita.
In 2017, at a local library
in Mahabalipurim, India,
Giorgio Tsoukalos meets with
fellow ancient astronaut
theorist Praveen Mohan to take
a closer look at the text.
Now this is a
vast medical text
that contains information about
more than 11,000 illnesses.
It talks about 700 medicinal
plants, 64 preparations
from mineral resources, 57
preparations from animal
resources, and it's
considered the foundation
of Ayurveda, the
traditional Indian medicine.
Oh, so this is the basis for
Ayurvedic medicine right here?
Yes.
I was able to find
a passage I thought
you might find interesting.
Right here.
You can see it says
that surgical operations
are of eight types.
They are incising,
excising, scraping,
puncturing, probing,
extracting, secreting
fluids, and even suturing.
So imagine we had
suturing 2,600 years ago.
And this book was written
more than 100 years
before Hippocrates, the
father of modern medicine.
That is amazing.
And how was this
information obtained?
Like, what's the
story behind this?
Well, the title
Sushruta Samhita
means that the author, Sushruta,
is not really the author.
He did not write this book.
He got this information
from a character
called Dhanvantari, who
was an other worldly being.
NARRATOR: Dhanvantari
is believed
to be the physician to
the gods, and the father
of Ayurvedic medicine.
EXPERT: Dhanvantari
itself has a divine origin
associated with the
churning of the milky ocean.
The churning of the
milk of sea refers
to perhaps the Milky Way.
Dhanvantari came out
of that, and then
he was the god of medicine,
and he then gave this knowledge
of medicine to human beings.
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS:
Dhanvantari was said to have
originated from the Milky Way.
And so all of a sudden,
you have a connection
with this deity arriving
from the Milky Way.
What more do you want?
The knowledge contained
in this document known
as the Sushruta Samhita
was brought here
by an extraterrestrial visitor.
NARRATOR: Ayurvedic
medicine is considered
one of the world's oldest and
most detailed healing sciences.
Is it possible that it
was really handed down
to mankind by alien sources?
Ancient astronaut
theorists say yes,
and suggest that
other texts clearly
reveal this
extraterrestrial connection.